hi guys hi guys
I ads I'm Greg I'm John I don't know
we're going to watch the trailer for the
u.s. trailer for this movie called
headshot oh boy we follow international
trailers for this people are saying hey
she check out the u.s. one I normally
prefer the International trailers for
the International films over the years
yeah let's see it's like people pitched
up to us away yeah let's see this though
[Music]
ramaa why here like him now you can't
hide it so anyway I don't even remember
my own name
she calls me Ishmael Eastern I don't
know what my life was before I met her
and I don't care she's what I need not
true man
[Music]
remember the father from hell
my father now I move away find my father
[Music]
[Music]
boy
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
ah
Oh
a guy's 1:09
[Music]
damn I won't die again
the trailer is like getting beaten up
it's like getting punched in the taste
like 100 times
I liked it yeah look what I liked it
Efrain I was hesitant at first because I
was like American trailer for an
international phone but that was a
really cool trailer maybe they got to
see the plot actually yeah or made more
sense this time lose a lot of time we
were like game pieces together
look I just follow Jason Bourne like a
bunny yeah yeah I wasn't this just
communicates to me like they throw all
in on [ __ ] oh yeah and film brutal
it's a roll leg they have a lot of those
shots where people are like in a
contained environment shooting let's go
rifle that each other like it's cool but
it's also like man you put so much work
into yeah like it's not just cool
anymore it's like wow that's impressive
I can hide in visually impressive
brutality yeah like I can't wait to see
this actually like good a trailer like
this reminds me of like why I love an
action movie yeah and I like a plot I
mean the guy have to kill his crazy
father that's a really I want thought of
a story like that about a girl actually
you're going to go take revenge and kill
her father hmm
we like revenge - I love revenge story a
lot already oh hell yeah now there's
some great advice but I mean I guess you
know I guess that's the most the most
human way to look at like to attach
yourself to a murderer well I feel like
revived I had a reason I feel like in
life revenge's or vengeance anything
like that is something that you know
it's frowned upon in real life you
shouldn't do it you shouldn't do it but
movies movies let you have just the good
feel and not the part where you're like
oh what if I do we all want to get
revenge in real life a lot of us shoes
not backside some of us do our own way a
movie has a great it's the easiest and
easiest to latch on to a feeling of this
is the villain you've done some bad [ __ ]
yeah now I want him dead
yeah that guy yeah yeah yeah I kill John
wick dog now we want him dead yeah if
you convince us hard enough like oh wow
this is a piece of [ __ ] I don't I don't
think we can help this guy
yeah go for it yeah quick simple premise
but you want to do know it's like a more
personal kind of board tail to me yeah
yeah the guy forgets his memory seems
like he remembers it pretty quick it
seems like it's like Jason Bourne of
Jason Brooke got the life that he wanted
at the end of this pretty like but first
though like in the second act yeah like
I just woke up and I want to live a cool
I am and now I know I gotta go kill my
yeah this looks like a really cool film
yeah is it in English I get I didn't
realize I couldn't tell if this was
blank dubbing because you don't actually
see them do any dialogue in English only
the one time when the girl says his name
but that's just his name I could just be
the way she pronounces it in any
language
so yeah I I couldn't tell if that was if
they dub this or if it actually will be
in English yeah I'm curious about that
too
either way I there I'm there a variety a
pretty good quote on there so he's yeah
variety is saying it chances are was
probably a good feelin pretty cool
alright guys next to us that was out are
you excited for head shot you guys know
the actual release date can you tell me
it can't seem to find it for some reason
I would love to see this movie
we knew the channel subscribe to the
real rejects John is reason to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram and the social
media manager of blue house and the real
rejects and if you guys have more
requests visit our new page facebook.com
slash the real rejects request copy and
paste the link to something you'd wanted
to check out makes our job a lot easier
instead of having to sort through a
bunch of comments and then we miss some
yeah and if you see some on the page you
want to give it a like so that we know
like how many people want what you know
yeah you to promotion stuff yeah find
this out it's going to be like e they're
a little I arrived
i watch videos on how the algorithms
[ __ ] up everyone's channel obey